non sinon jacques on vous annonce que
votre mec une ancienne passé de 9 en ré
des meufs de type nobel comme ça exact
possible
waouh super impressionnant exactement la
même chose c'est bon tu as ta place
voilà on a une petite surprise
on voulait savoir enfin que tu ouvres ça
et tu es un jeans qu'il fallait a dit à
la caméra ce que cet objet une cassette
vidéo
cette vidéo met un blu ray alors ça
c'était pour écouter la musique j'ai
écouté ça à la base des marines up c'est
tout m
mais non vraiment c'est la bonne blague
c'est vraiment un téléphone de l'époque
et regarde la plaie ou alors ça m'a
quand même dit qu'elle 7
vidéo saint-hyacinthe audio ça aussi
c'est une cassette audio fait à lille
les objets et qu'est ce que tu fais
édition tournage on va être extrêmement
jeune stagiaire mon boulot consiste en
quoi un regard alors qu'est ce que tu
avais regardées est ce que le film
parvient déjà parce que je trouve que
non c'est de la merde je trouve qu'on a
enfin vu que si tu es jeune et un peu
plus jeune que nous l éloge de bons jeux
totalement le g8 va en faire ça c'est
disons plus souffre bien gros coup de
vieux enfin qu'on a oublié des trucs à
chauny est ce qu'on parle la jeunesse en
omettant certaines choses de 7,10 des
années mc je sais pas par exemple je
fais un courant ou un truc qui ne me
connaissent pas la plus grosse mode en
ce moment tu as été 14 ans j'ai 14 ans
théo collège qu'il faut absolument de
cache t ou que tu fasses fotso populaire
met d'accord mais ce genre d'avis bien
parce que ça existe encore et skyblog
non c'est fini ça c'est fini
non c'est quoi vraiment parce que
facebook facebook facebook et pour
sectionner berry bbm d'accord en fait tu
vas genre dans ton film tu dis que
le jeune et j'ai excuse moi je prendrais
de saint jacques mais après c'est pour
te parler à tort mais si tu dis que le
jet des adultes se ressemblent plus en
plus que je trouve que même nadeau il
préférait 12 son genre le jeune adulte
et le pré ados donc tout jeune
adolescent comme alice qui à 14 h sur
semble de plus en plus jeunes ben ali ce
match plein où jamais on était aussi
cool que des mecs que de 25 ans et demi
de loris et les mecs de 14 ans qui sont
plus que nous assurer que ça je peux
approcher quoi jeu mais c'est vrai alors
enfin aujourd'hui long on a les mêmes
intérêts que nous disons c'est c'est
carrément plus super cool de voir 24 ans
et bombay proust et cargo les gourmands
les grandes bouffes lors des limites à
la meuf de 15 ans elle sort avec un
nikkei en a 35 ans et sa crainte qu'au
niveau des façons enfin c'est un peu
superficiel mais au niveau des biens
c'est à dire je peux aller les portables
et/ou la mesa possible et ce après bien
s'habiller important l'asie qui tous et
c'est que ça c'est vachement maintenant
tu as raison achement même chose quoi
bon exemple parce que tu vois on écoute
on a eu vite fait les mêmes choses tu
vas enfin j'veux pas être comme moi tu
écoutes tokio hotel la nature et après
c'est que bon enfin si tu fais ça répond
après c'est le sardine pas ton statut
qui changent même après le chemin j'ai
l'impression que l'enfance c'est un an
plus tôt de cette limite habitant
maintenant faire un jour c'est chaud
enfin on met chaque jeune en troisième
j'ai donc besoin de bien longues
enfin c'était ça que 14 ans je
commençais à 14 ans je t'ai rencontré
devrait carrément gay mais du coup de
tentes en troisième [ __ ] mais moi en
troisième
je joue au yoyo quoi mais sérieux elle
est la même la grosse moi c'était yoyo
pokémon
je regardais encore dix gymnastes et là
encore tu vois ça mais bon c'est simple
est simple les [ __ ] squats ou non à la
police explique timothée pas les points
non franchement moi tout le monde est ok
maintenant le mec cool qui sert des
meufs et j'avais des images pokémon en
primaire j'imagine qu'ils vont jouer en
crèche j'étais un peu on en fait quoi
c'est bizarre ces deux jeunes sont de
culte de plus en plus passer les mini
adultes familles adultes tout paraît que
les adultes sauf le métier
impressionnant mais bah ouais c'est
bizarre c'est même le fait qu'ils aient
des blackberry ou des iphone tu veux hp
à la base c'est un truc quand à une vie
un peu remplie et toi tu veux toujours
nourri ce qui faisait avec que genre
[ __ ] attends je vais voter mon rendez
vous fut mon cas la paume bonjour un
goûter avec mon pote tu allais puisque
jusqu'à tes 20 ans t'as rien à faire de
spécial n'avait que les tiots pattes à
un gros con de merde ça veut dire sa
dictée encore dicté s'arrêter là mais
sait-on jamais écouté faut bien que je
passe en grande section basket admettre
que le trade entre que la nuit tombe au
pied
un tournage à toronto par mois pour
assurer une surprise pour toi quoi
accord pour toi c'est quoi cet objet je
vais réfléchir monde ont accès libre non
c'est que cette vidéo